what are your thoughts when you're
hearing this of U.S not being as
involved to help the people where maybe
in other times they got a little bit
more help than they're getting right now
you're talking about Iran
right yeah I'm talking about like
because you know for them to do what
they want to do they're going to need
some sort of a help outside the people
or not the government so there's a big
difference like for example if we're
talking uh if we're talking uh Armenia
against Azerbaijan okay the The Armenian
people and the government The Armenian
people are not revolting against him
they're on the same page they need help
here's money Ukraine is like dude we're
on the same page we need help they're
attacking us right but Iranian people
their government is hurting them so a
regime has to come in and help the
people out and it's not happening why is
Iran not helping out prediction United
States sold over trillion dollars after
brought Khomeini to Iran it's not in
there you said they sold they sold
trillion dollars of arm in last 43 years
to the Middle Eastern Area because of
their making one country scary hey you
gotta buy this against them hey you're
gonna buy this weapon against that's
what is happening Iran I mean with how
many come to Iran seven War happened 48
million refugees one and a half a
million killed over 3 million disabled
this is a gift of one mistake United
States foreign policy should change must
change enough already making Al-Qaeda
support Al-Qaeda give him so much money
and then they they give against them
enough making uh Boko Haram or whatever
all those ices and all of them and then
later on turning against to become a
terrorist of the uh area
if you're going back and you see what
these things happening is a mistake of
foreign policy of the United States but
there are a lot of Iranians there are a
lot of Iranians that also I hear from
that don't want foreign intervention
because a lot of people do see the
reason we're even here is because of
foreign intervention partially so there
is that argument too that has to come
from within how it's going to come from
within I also don't have the answer but
but there's a difference because uh
and here's how I see the foreign
intervention the the difference between
there's another documentary that uh uh
why uh the revolution of Iran happened
talking about what they did to the shop
because Shah was becoming too powerful
for example
if
if you're living in a society where the
the people at the top are abusing people
okay say you and I are here we go to a
restaurant okay
we see a guy that's hitting a girl slaps
her in the face what are you going to
tell me to do so I'm not going to tell
you I'm gonna go interview that's right
so it's so but should we intervene I
would but should we yes so we should yes
but yes but wait a minute that's
different but no it's not it's not
different because in this situation 12
year olds are getting killed yeah okay
so it's not like with the Shah Shah was
killing 12 year olds it's not like the
shaw was forcing 52 year olds to marry
nine it's a very different perspective
for you then but let me wrap this point
up so for me you know in a in a in a
situation like this these are two
different situations if my my sister is
married to her husband
they're having a fight it's not my
business I'm not intervening zero if my
wife and I are having a fight my dad
lives with my my dad's biggest reason
why he didn't want to live with us for
10 years I've been trying to get this
guy to live with us you know what's the
number one reason I don't want to come
in between you and your wife never like
if we fight guess what my dad does goes
upstairs he goes to his room he says
it's your business yeah okay he goes
it's your business no problem but I tell
you if I even it's never happened it's
not but if if I did something he's the
first one that's going to come in and
say I'm intervening right so I think you
know as much as you say some Iranians
are saying that I understand it's like
the Diplomatic politically correct thing
to say for some not saying all of them
some of them want to say something like
that
this is a very different situation
they're currently in right now well I'm
not talking about diaspora Iranian
saying this I'm talking about Iranians
inside everyone but my question to you
was if you you are saying they need
intervention so how do you propose that
to happen what can even happen how can
you get anything I think we gotta we the
United States has to be the number one
to step up they got to put sanction on
it we always do sanctions on Russia and
everybody we got to get Hands-On because
like you said if it's going to be rocks
against bullets they're not gonna I love
them to death and I'm with them 100
you're not going to win that battle and
I I don't know here's my question you
guys why aren't we getting as involved
with not like like Ukraine and all this
why are we because they're trying to
negotiate the Jason that's what I was
gonna yeah I mean that's my that's what
I would think is happening so do you
have an answer that you guys have an
answer because I have a rebuttal here
okay so let me let me give my feedback
to you on how to help on something like
that and I I know it's not going to be a
popular one for you because of where you
lean politically but I'll give it to you
so you know sometimes uh um
um Paulette for instance I was the
annoying younger brother super
protective okay
I'm exactly who you think I was so when
my sister would date guys
uh you know it was just a bad situation
she did not want me around right because
my parents got a divorce so naturally
from 10 years old when they got a
divorce I was the brother I was supposed
I have to play that role naturally no
problem
so when when you have somebody annoying
like that in your life you don't want
them around too much because it's like
man let me just live my life and just
don't bother me right
until all of a sudden
something happens where there's really a
need then you say you know what
this is a situation where I wish that
brother of mine that was like that would
be here to protect me against XYZ is
that 90 of the time no it's ten percent
of the time
when uh uh Trump was President okay
put sanctions on top of sanctions on top
of sanctions on top of sanctions on top
of sanctions on top of sanctions to the
point where Iran was about to go through
the revolution it was very close whether
we got about to go to the revolution
and he says no we support the Iranian
people no we support the Iranian people
he pulled out of the 150 billion dollars
with Kerry and Obama so now we're not
going to be doing this pulled out pull
that pulled out we're not going to be
doing this we're not going to be doing
this we're not going to be doing this
and then the moment the regime changes
no this is back on the table let's talk
about it we're removing this we're
removing that and then they start
getting free I was in Monaco one time
and we're having
can't even mention the person's name but
the person is involved in the economy of
the 21 countries that they're dealing
with the economy and all this stuff says
listen the moment sanctions were given
we had to call every Bank in the Middle
East to say you can't do any business
with people in Iran he says he was legit
when that took place like when you're
saying business is shutting down oil
shutting down you got to bring the pain
to the government right unfortunately
the current regime can do that but
they're not doing that and they're
playing negotiation there's a famous guy
back in the days his name was Ronald he
says you don't negotiate with terrorists
we've been negotiating with terrorists
for too long and I don't think you
shouldn't negotiate with terrorists so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]